[Music]
who do you think is the biggest underdog
doesn't doesn't say which and actually
towards a point to an underdog I mean I
buy rating Peter is I guess underdog but
I mean he had so many tournament
victories and successes over the course
of his career that it wouldn't really be
a surprise would be fighting for first
place using uh you know me you've met me
right
I should firmly establish myself as the
underdog in this tournament before the
tournament starts I think there's a
little survey wealth elite for the good
miserably with sharks are safe but I
generally consult consider myself an
underdog so I would think that I'm an
advocate now it's difficult to pick a
favorite in the first place so you know
you asking me to pick an underdog and
like be even more difficult and maybe
not very flattering for for the player
will I will pick as is could be could be
basically anybody I mean there there's
nobody in this tournament that you
expected exactly welcome one of the last
times that Magnus won a tournament
yeah it's been nasty
biggest underdog well maybe Sergei
Kuryakin because like in the candidates
last year no one really expected him to
refresh and win first place but in
important advance he seems to manage to
push through extra base things there is
no one because there is no week's square
cure so perhaps maybe I would say like
napalm Miyaichi if anyone just because
based on the ratings but I don't exactly
when underdog
well okay anyone can be underdog assist
arranger shows that you know it like
that and anything can happen it I don't
really think there's future papers that
you changes with here now to talk about
the wrapping up blitz I think the
biggest underdog
I mean maybe underdogs wrong word but I
think the expectations for what Gary
does will be quite interesting
can you go get Ian on the dog haha
[Laughter]